you've seen a lot of functions in
introductory calculus trig functions
rational functions Exponential's logs
and so on I don't know whether your
calculus course has included a general
discussion of functions the
old-fashioned ones didn't and we will go
into that now in this segment and we're
going to be interpreting functions as a
special case of binary relations so
let's just say what a binary relation is
a binary relation is a mathematical
object that associates elements of one
set called the domain with elements of
another set called the codomain and I'm
gonna give you a bunch of examples of
binary relations you know in a short
moment but let's just talk about what
they're for and what their role is so
they may be Camilla familiar to you as
computer scientists if you've worked
with any relational databases like SQL
or MySQL my sequel and will see an
example that indicates where the
original ideas behind those relational
databases came from but even more
fundamental relations are one of the
most basic mathematical abstractions
right after sets and they play a role
everywhere we're going to be looking in
later lectures as special kinds of
binary relations like equivalence
relations and partial orders and
numerical congruence --is but today
we're gonna set up the machinery to be
using binary relations for counting
which will be another important
application in this class so let's look
at an example and I'm gonna take one
that's close to home the registered for
relation which is a relation between
students that's going to be the domain
in this case for students Jason Joan
away and Adam and subjects for subjects
as a coincident 6:04 to double O 3 0 1 2
and double o4 and the relation R is
going to be indicated by
arrows would show just which students
are associated with which subjects
meaning that they're registered for that
subject so if we look at Jason we can
see that there there's a particular
arrow connecting Jason and 604 2 and
what that tells us is that Jason is
registered for 604 - now there's a bunch
of notations that are used with respect
to binary relations so let's look at
some one way to write it is if you think
of the relation R as like an equality
sign or a less than sign where it's
normally written in the middle of the
two things that it's connecting as in
this example Jason R 604 2 that would be
called in fix notation sometimes it's
written as a binary predicate R of Jason
comma 604 - that would be kind of prefix
notation where the relation or operator
comes first and then if you start being
a little closer to the formal definition
of what a binary relation is you could
say that the ordered pair jason 604 2 is
a member of the relation if you wanted
to be really precise you would say that
it was a member of the graph of the
relation and I'll come back and
elaborate further on what the graph of a
relation is and and what this ordered
pairs business is but for now just let's
continue with this example and a basic
concept with relations is the idea of
the image of a bunch of domain elements
under the relation so you can think of
the relation as an operator that applies
to domain elements or even sets of
domain elements so if I write R of Jason
that defines the subjects that jason is
registered for so looking at the picture
or is not a function so that there may
be more than one subject as is you'd
expect for a student to be registered
for multiple courses at MIT so Jason in
this diagram is registered for 604 - and
601 - as indicated by the
highlighted two connection arrows which
we've made red which means that our of
Jason is that set of two courses that
he's associated there that he's
associated with or that are associated
with him that he's registered for 604
two and 601 - so at this point we've
applied our - one domain element one
student Jason but the interesting case
is when you apply are to a bunch of
students so the general setup is that if
X is a set of students a subset of the
domain which we've been showing in green
then if I apply R to X it gives me all
the subjects that they're taking among
them all the subjects that any one of
them is taken let's take a look at an
example well another way to say it I
guess is that R of X is everything in
our that relates to things in X so if I
look at Jason and a way and I want to
know what are they connected what do
they connect to under R these are the
subjects that Jason or equated four-way
I'd find that is by looking at the arrow
diagram and I find that Jason is taking
oh four two and oh one two and eva is
taking oh one two and double oh four so
between them they're taking three
courses so R of Jason a way is in fact
oh four two oh one two and double oh
four
so another way to understand this idea
of the image of a set R of X is that X
is a set of points in the set that
you're starting with called the domain
and R of X is going to be all of the
endpoints in the other set the code
domain that start at X if I said that as
a statement in formal logic or in set
theory with logical notation I would say
that R of X is the set of J in subjects
such that there is the in X
such that D RJ so what that that's
exactly saying that d rj says that D is
the starting point in the domain D is a
student J is a subject the RJ means
there's an arrow that goes from student
D to subject J and we're collecting the
set of those J's that start at some D so
an arrow from X goes to J is what exists
at the in X the RJ means written in
logic notation it's really talking about
the endpoints of arrows and that's a
nice way to think about it but you ought
to be able also to retreat to give a
nice crisp set theoretic definition
without reference to pictures if need be
so that's an official definition of the
image under R let's turn now to an
operation on relations which converts
one relation into another relation
called the inverse of r and the inverse
of R is what you get by turning the
arrows around so let's look at the
relation R which is the registered for
relation going from these students to J
subjects and then if I look at our
inverse or inverse I could think of as
the registers relations 604 2 registers
Jason and and 601 2 registers jason and
a way it's a funny usage of the word but
I needed something short that would fit
on the slide so registers is basically
turning the arrows backwards of is
registered for and now I can apply the
definition of image to R inverse in a
useful way but just to be crisp about
what we're doing here is formally our
inverse has gotten by flipping the role
of the domain and the code domain so we
have that drj if and only if J R inverse
D so let's look at our inverse of 601 to
what that's gonna mean is all the
students that are taking 601 to
so we start off at 6:01 - and we go back
to all the students that are registered
for it it's Jason and a way again and so
our inverse of 601 to is Jason anyway
our inverse of 601 to and six double O
three well same deal let's look at six
double O three and six oh one two and
look at all the students that are
registered for either one of them now
it's Jason Joan and equation by those
red arrows those all the arrows coming
out of those two courses double of three
and a one two and so our inverse of the
below three and a one two is that set of
three students Jason Joan and a way and
in general when you start off with a
bunch of subjects a bunch of elements of
the codomain and you apply our inverse
to it it's called the inverse image of Y
under R well let's look at the set J of
all the subjects and think about what is
our inverse of J what does it mean well
our inverse of J is all the students
that are registered for some subject at
all which is a good thing to have so now
I can start using these sets to make to
make assertions about my database that
can be useful to know so for example if
I want to say that every student is
registered for some subject which of
course they are what I would say is that
V the set of all students is a subset of
R inverse of J so this concise set
theoretic in a containment statement D
is a subset of R inverse of J is a slick
way of writing the precise statement
that says that all the students are
registered for some subject now it
happens not to be true by the way
because if you look back at that example
Adam was not registered for a subject so
we're not claiming this is true but
simply that there's a nice way to
express it using images and containment
let's look at a different relation that
we could call the advisors relation now
so the advisors relation is gonna have
codomain the same set of students D but
it's gonna have as a domain the set of
professors and I've written down the
initials of five prominent professors -
at the top and you may recognize some of
the others but it doesn't really matter
if you don't and the advisors relation V
is going to be indicated by those arrows
so in particular it shows that a RM is
the advisor of Jason Joan equation Adam
which he happens to be FPL is an advisor
of Joan and away so Joan has two
advisors because she's a double major he
way does as well and Adam does as well
now that I look at this example so if I
look at in particular now the advisees
of FTL or TLP I'm looking at V of the
set consisting of FTL and TLP and it's
going to be Joan equal and atom so
taking the image of FTL and TLP that
that's the set of advisees of either of
those two professors I get this set of
three students Joan a way and Adam well
that's a set of students and the
registered relation applies to a set of
students so let's do that
if I now apply our to Joan and eat way
and Adam what I'm getting is the
subjects that they're registered for so
this is called composing R and V I've
applied V and then I'm applying our to
the result in this case R of V of FTL
and TLP is the same as R of Jony way and
Adam it's the courses that any of them
are taken taking and it's double O 301 -
and double O four so the way to
understand this R of V in general is you
start off with any set X of professors
in the domain you take V of X
are the advisees that they have and then
you take our of the advisees and you get
the subjects that the advisees are taken
so R of V of X is the subjects that
advisees of X are taking are registered
for well we can abstract that out and
call this the composition of R and V
it's defined the same way that
functional composition is so R of V is
the relation and the images of that
relation the images of a set of
professors under our V is defined to be
apply V - X and then apply our - V of X
and it's again called the composition of
R and V what it means now is that two
things are related by our a V it relates
professors and subjects and it says that
a professor and a subject are related if
the professor has an advisee some
advisee in that subject P for a
professor composition of our with V J
for a subject holds if and only if
professor P has an advisee registered in
subject J let's see how you figure that
kind of thing out so I'm gonna draw the
V relation which goes from P professors
to these students and then the our
relation that goes from these students
to J subjects and by showing them in
this way I can understand the
composition of R and V as following two
arrows you start off say at a RM and you
follow a V arrow from a RM to his
advisee away then you follow another
arrow from a way to 601 - and you
discover hey a RM has an advisee in so
now we can say that professor a RM is in
the relation R composed with V with 601
- because of this path a RM has a way as
an advisee and a way is registered for
601 - and this relation ro V we figured
out
the relation that the professor has an
advisee in the subject so in general
what we can say is that a professor
payee is in the ROV relation to Jay if
and only if and here we're going to
state it in formal logical notation
which really applies in general and not
just to this particular example so the
definition of our composed with V is
that P are composed with VJ means
there's a D that connects P and J
through V and D in particular that
there's a D such that P V D which means
there's an arrow of V arrow from P to D
and the RJ there's an R arrow from v2 j
for some D by the way there's a
technicality here that when you write
the formula P V D and the RJ following
the diagram where you start with V on
the left and follow of ero and then an R
arrow it's natural to think of them as
written in left-to-right order of what
you apply first V R but of course that's
not the way composition works when you
apply a one function or 2v2 something
you're applying v first and you write it
on the right so ro V is written like
function composition where V applies
first but the logical statement the
natural way to write it is to follow the
way the picture works and the v's and
ours get reversed so watch out for that
confusion well I want to introduce one
more relation to flesh out this example
and that'll be the teaches relation so
the teacher's relation is going to have
as domain professors again and as Co
domain subjects and it's simply gonna
tell us who's teaching what so here
we're going to see that a RM is teaching
604 - as you well know an FTL is
teaching 604 - which he does frequently
but not this term and now I can again
use my relational operators to start
making assertions about this about these
people in relation
involving teaching and advisees so I
ended the useful way to do that is by
applying set operations to the relations
because I can think of the relations as
being that set of arrows so suppose I
wanted to make some statement that a
professor should not teach their own
advisee because it's too much powerful
one person to have over a student this
is not true by the way it's common for
professors to teach advisees but there
are other kinds of rules about dual
relationships between supervisory
relationships and personal relationships
but anyway let's say if we can say that
profs should not supervise or should not
teach any one that they're advising well
if we were saying that in logical
notation what we would say is that for
every professor and subject it's not the
case that the professor has an advisee
in subject J and the professor is
teaching subject J so that's how you say
it in logic but there's a very slick way
to say it without all the formulas and
the quantifiers I could just say that T
the relationship of his teaching
intersected with the relationship of has
an advisee in the subject is empty there
is no pair of professor and subject that
is in both T and in R of V and this
bottom expression here gives you a sense
of the concise way that you can express
queries and assertions about the
database using a combination of
relational operators and set operators
another way to say it by the way there's
a general set theoretic fact is the way
to say that T and R of V intersected is
empty is to say that they that the set T
and the set R of V whatever they are
have no points in common an equivalent
way to say that is that one set is
contained in the complement of the other
set so I could equally well have said
this as R composed with V is
subset of not T well let's step back now
and summarize what we've done by example
and say a little bit about what it how
it works in general so as I said a
binary relation um and we'll start to be
slightly more formal now a binary
relation are from a set a to a set B
associates elements of a with elements
of B and there's a picture of a general
set a called the domain and a general
set B called the codomain and R is given
by those arrows well what exactly are
arrows well if you're gonna formalize
arrows the set of them is what's called
the graph of R so technically a relation
really has three parts it's not to be
identified with just its arrows a
relation has a domain and a code domain
and some bunch of arrows going from the
domain to the code domain the arrows can
be formalized by saying all that matters
about an arrow is where it begins and
where it ends because it's just designed
to reflect an association between an
element of the domain and an element of
the codomain so technically the arrows
are just ordered pairs and in this case
there are three arrows one from A to B
to and so you see at the bottom of the
slide an ordered pair a one B to another
arrow goes from a1 to b4 so you see the
ordered pair a1 before and the final
arrow is BA three beef four and you see
that pair so all the language about
arrows is really talking about ordered
pairs it's just that the geometric
vision image of these diagrams of their
arrows makes a lot of properties much
clearer so the range of R is an
important concept that comes up
regularly and tends to be a little
confusing for people the range of R is
simply the elements with arrows coming
in from our it's all of the elements
that are hit by an arrow that starts
in the domain so it's really our of the
domain is the range of our now notice
that this is typically not equal to the
whole code domain let's look at this
example here the range of our are the
hit the points that are hit by elements
of a under our namely just B 2 and B 4
the codomain has elements B 1 in B 3
that are missing and that are not in the
range well as I said functions are a
special case of relation so let's just
look at that a function f from a set a
to a set B is a relation which
associates with each element in the
domain each element little a in the
domain capital a with at most one
element of the codomain B so this one
element if it exists is called F of a
it's the image of the element a under
the relation F but what's special about
it is that F of a contains at most one
element so let's just look at an example
again a way to say that that a relation
is a function is to look at all of the
points on the left in the in the domain
and make sure that none of them have
more than one arrow coming out well in
this picture there are a couple of
violations about that of that there are
a couple of points on the left in a that
have more than one arrow coming out
there's our two bad edges but if I erase
those now I'm left with a function and
sure enough there's at most one arrow
coming out of each of the points on the
left in a some of the points have no
arrows coming out that's fine and so for
those green points with an arrow out
there's a unique F of the Green Point
equal to a magenta point in B that's
uniquely determined by the functional
relation F which may not be defined for
all of the green points if they don't
have any arrow coming out of them so
function means less than or equal to one
arrow coming out
so if we set this formally without
talking about the arrows one way is
simply to say that that a relation is a
function
if f of little a is let if the size of f
of little a is less than or equal to 1
for all of the domain elements a and a
more elementary way to say it using just
the language of relations and equality
and boolean connectives is to say that
if a is connected to two things by F if
a FB and a FB prime then in fact B is
equal to B Prime and that wraps up
functions